as a psychiatrist yourself can you do a
deep analysis of this other famous
psychiatrist which is the movie
character
played by robin williams at goodwill
hunting
this is just a caricature between a
psychiatrist and patient relationship
or is there some
something to you was that was moving
about his ability to connect to this
obviously struggling young kid
i think you've hit on the key thing
there which is the the depth of the
connection if
if there's a
too powerful connection
that can impair uh therapy because it
could impair
open communication if if someone
if a patient has a
sees the role sees the relationship in a
particular way
like in a friendly way maybe or like a
parental
child type
way that can cause problems because then
what they choose to share what they
choose to bring up
is
selected to be appropriate for that
view of the relationship
and so i and many other talk therapists
actually prefer
uh not to let things get
not let the connection get that deep
you want to have trust you want to have
a therapeutic alliance we sometimes call
it
but it's got to be enough of a blank
slate
that the patient
is not
consciously or unconsciously constrained
in what they choose to share
and so
great movie
great actors
all good no complaints except uh
realistically
the relationship should be a little more
uh arm's length than that
let's pretend this is real life
sometimes
can't you leave a little bit of yourself
in the interaction with the patient i
mean it's another human being yes so
it's a balance and actually you do need
some of it um because let's say this
person is having
challenges interpersonal challenges in
their life
the best way
to notice what those are
and to identify them and to work with
them is if you can elicit some of those
problems
in
in the office in the therapeutic
interaction
and
this is really powerful as long as
you're
alert to it aware of it
and you don't let it go out of hand
this transference we call it is when
you
transfer
in between the current therapeutic
relationship and
external relationships that the patient
may have had with others
and so if the therapist starts to feel
an inner feeling
like anger
let's say so let's say you have a
patient who is stirring
frustration in you or even an extreme
case is anger
the the best thing for the therapist to
do in that case is to recognize it
and to realize
that's probably being stirred by other
people in the patient's life and that
could be the source of a lot of problems
and so instead of trying to wall it off
and say oh i shouldn't be feeling that i
better be a better therapist instead and
recognize it and use it
and help the patient that way and so
you've got to be a human being you've
got to be a person who feels and you've
got to be open
but be in control of it and be aware of
it
if if i may i just want to read the
because my favorite scenes probably one
of the greatest scenes
one of the greatest scenes in movie
history because robin williams does a
single take
is that right so this is a very
interesting interaction between them so
um will and i'm sure this is a common
interaction
um
maybe with a therapist and a patient
maybe with a father and son
where
will the young character the young
brilliant mathematician and sean as the
therapist the older
uh therapist where will looks at a
painting that sean
painted and then does a like a deep
critical analysis of the painting that
basically you know describes
pretending as if he can understand
another human being completely but just
looking at their painting
and then sean gives this whole speech
that contrasts sort of raw intelligence
and the wisdom of experience
and sean says single take
he says you've never been out of boston
right and will says nope
all this in a sexy boston accent by the
way
uh and then sean gives the speech
if i asked you about art you probably
give me this skinny and about every art
book ever written michelangelo
you know a lot about him life's work
political aspirations him and the pope
sexual orientation the whole works right
but i bet you can't tell me what it
smells like in the sistine chapel
you never actually stood there and
looked up at that beautiful ceiling seen
that
if i asked you about women you'll
probably give me a syllabus of your
personal favorites
you may have
even been laid a few times
the language here is just beautiful
but but you can't tell me what it feels
like to wake up next to a woman and feel
truly happy
you're a tough kid
if i asked you about war you probably
throw shakespeare at me right probably
not but let's say
once more into the breach dear friends
but you've never been near one you've
never held your best friend's head on
your lap and watch him gasp his last
breath looking to you for help
if i ask you about love
you'd probably quote me a sonnet
but you've never looked at a woman and
be truly vulnerable
known someone who can level you with
their eyes
feeling like god put an angel on earth
just for you
who could rescue you from the depths of
hell and you wouldn't know what it's
like to be
her angel
to have that love for her
be there forever through anything
through cancer
and you wouldn't know about sleeping
sitting up in a hospital room for two
months holding her hand because the
doctors could see in your eyes the terms
visiting hours don't apply to you
you don't know about real loss because
that only occurs
when you love something more than you
love yourself
i doubt you've ever dared to love
anybody that much
i look at you
i don't see an intelligent confident man
i see a cocky scared shitless kid
but you're a genius well no one denies
that
no one can possibly understand the
depths of you but you presumed to know
everything about me because you saw a
painting of mine
you rip my [ __ ] life apart
you're an orphan right
do you think i know the first thing
about how hard your life has been how
you feel
who you are because i read oliver twist
does that encapsulate you personally i
don't give a [ __ ] about all that because
you know what
i can't learn anything from you that i
can't read in some [ __ ] book
unless you want to talk about you who
you are and i'm fascinated i'm in but
you don't want to do that do you sport
you're terrified of what you might say
your move chief
well done sir i know it's a movie it's
interesting right so some of that
conversation is just some intellectual
level too
it's not just emotional it's something
uh it's like i the reason i kind of
connect with that is
that's a lot of work
for a therapist
like to really understand another
because he's i mean from it okay i know
this is fictional but just
there's calculation happening he deeply
cares
to say the words that the other person
needs to hear but also a little bit
loses himself in
the pride
but then catches himself again
switches from anger to uh to connection
yeah
a lot is brought up there that you're
right there there has to be some emotion
in the therapist to care enough to keep
going to to keep probing to open up
as he's doing so right
he revealed a lot about himself his own
vulnerabilities but that gave him
authenticity
he had to open himself up so that the
the kid would see the authenticity and
open himself up in return
so so how do you do that as a as a as a
psychiatrist as a therapist
you have to be careful you know you
don't want to do too much uh but opening
up a little bit
does
help it does create uh a chance you know
you're offering up something and that
helps the patient come back in return
and it gives it gives you that that uh
believability and authenticity do you
pay the price for that for opening it up
you can um
you have a family you have an incredibly
like difficult research like you're
doing a lot of things in your world i
mean it's the price you pay for like
well this is one of the terrifying
things about about writing the book was
was
i i do open up uh in a little bit about
my own personal life my own personal
challenges and that was a considered
decision because
uh i could i could have
done
the the patient work and the science
work and the and the history of the
human family work and and tied it all
together but but it wasn't
and i in an early draft it was it was
like that
but it wasn't it wasn't real yet it
wasn't
it wasn't uh something that that
everybody could connect with and i said
then i realized look if i'm going to do
this
i've gotta i've gotta open up myself and
then and then people can connect with me
and
see
what i'm really saying and so i did and
that was
it was not something that um i'd gone in
planning to do
in retrospect i learned a lot about
myself it was actually really i think a
good thing that i i did but
it was scary
where the darkest places you've ever
gone in your life
you know i had uh
things haven't haven't always been been
easy personally or you know or
professionally i had i had moments you
know i was effectively a single dad for
for a while a number of years and these
came at probably the hardest also
professional
life times for me too
the absolute hardest uh days of late
medical school internship you know
taking call
you know getting up at 3am you know
surgery
uh
medicine rounds unforgiving environments
and then all the while you know personal
life uh you know stripped down to the
bear
and these were low moments and then i
was hit particularly hard by
just experiences on
on the clinical ward connecting too
deeply with patients like you know a
child with a brain tumor and feeling it
too strongly and and those things
uh
when you get down to those lowest of the
low moments when everything is is
stripped away and and there's there's
only this this raw
core well
that's pretty hard those are that was
probably the the lowest moment and you
learn a lot about yourself in those
moments you know what's what's left and
and then what are the
the roots out from there and and that's
that's that can be powerful to to see
in yourself
you